scientists almost entirely agree the
last three decades have been
successfully warmer at the Earth's
surface than any since 1850 in the
northern hemisphere the last 30 years
have been the warmest on record in the
last 800 years while as evidence sea ice
is increasing in some parts of
Antarctica it is decreasing in the
Arctic at 4 percent per decade during
the summer months that melting of the
sea ice can increase over threefold in
terms of area that's like losing the
size of Japan Vietnam and Malaysia in
ice every decade shrinking glaciers have
also added to rising sea levels that
rise in the last century has been faster
than during the previous two millennia
and while a 1.7 millimeter a year
increase doesn't sound too bad
levels have risen nearly twice as fast
in the last 20 years the UN is even
confident climate change is responsible
for droughts reduced crops and the
extinction of several species this is
mostly thanks to rapid industrialization
in just over 20 years global greenhouse
gas emissions have risen by over 40
percent back in 1990 the biggest
offender was the USA with nearly 17
percent of the world's emissions China's
dramatic ascent as a global power has
seen it pinch the top spot with 22
percent of the world's emissions the
Asian powerhouse gave the green light to
155 coal plants this year alone despite
over capacity with warnings of the
planet facing irreversible damage time
is running out for the world's advanced
nations to come to the most important
agreement of our time